c'est las vegas orange dans blade runner
c'est le travail du bureau montréalais
du studio frings tour et ils n'en sont
pas peu fiers sans casser le côté
réaliste en fait de la chose même si
c'est orange c'est quand même assez
théoriquement si c'est quelque chose de
très très bonnes mais on va pas loin du
tout on veut quand même montré
l'environnement donc il faut trouver un
peu le bon entre deux duos jusqu'où on
peut voir deux ou en rajouter très rodéo
fx a prolongé des environnements pour
élargir la perspective le studio devant
des glaives a réalisé le los angelès du
futur et la campagne virtuelle de cas
moving picture company a eu la délicate
tâche de ramener à la vie la rachel du
blé brunot original gas réussir à créer
de façon complètement numérique une
figure humaine c'est le saint graal des
effets spéciaux chez moving pictures on
espère que l'académie reconnaîtra le
travail accompli denis villeneuve de par
sa vision des effets visuels a poussé
les studios à sortir de leur zone de
confort
donc ça nous a appris à un peu mettre de
côté ce qu'on a l'habitude de faire
ajouter du contraste dans les images des
spéculaire et tout ça est de garder les
choses un peu plus soft est vraiment
simple mais bien fait
si montréal est aussi reconnue en
matière d'effets visuels c'est parce que
c'est une expertise qu'on développe
depuis longtemps sur un bassin de
créateurs qui sont là depuis les années
80 90 qui ont participé à la création
des logiciels des techniques de cinéma
donc tous les tous les outils qui sont
usées venant à voir les créateurs et ça
c'est monique gens non plus pour les
compagnies qui viennent ici parce que
bon ils ont accès à une expertise qui
ont connaisseurs mayer
libre à nous radio canada montréal